the presidential records act does not
confer any mandatory or even
discretionary Authority or the archivist
to classify records folks under the
statute this responsibility is left
solely to the president of the United
States think of Donald Trump was not
president when he committed the alleged
acts for which he has been indicted this
is it seems like just Trump reading
stuff off of one of the very
teleprompters he criticizes others for
using it seems like it's just more of
that but legal experts have looked at
that 37 second video clip and come away
realizing Trump is admitting to crimes
and he is also stating law
presidential records act I guess we can
call it law that is not the law under
which he is charged